well the summer night 2016 meeting
between a Russian lawyer and Donald
Trump jr. has of course become the
centerpiece for the Russia collusion
conspiracy theory that is completely
overwhelmed the workings of government
increasingly though that meeting looks
like it may have been a setup designed
from the outset to sabotage the Trump
campaign Lee Smith has looked carefully
at this here actual real clear
investigations here's a brand new piece
out on it today which you should read
it's fascinating and he joins us tonight
Lee so you took a you took a very close
look at this meeting what did you
conclude
yeah thanks Tucker for having me on I
think what I think one of the most
important things to to look at it's
actually there's one key to it and that
is the Russian lawyer
that is supposed to be the test of the
proof of collusion this was a client to
Glenn Simpson and Glenn Simpson was the
person who was responsible for producing
the Clinton funded dossier so how does
this happen
how did this combination happen how are
all these people in the same room I
think that's the essential point that's
been alighted or obscured almost all the
time in the press and I think that once
the people look at that fact things
start to become clearer and you're
speaking of vessel nets kya is that
correct yes exactly to tell you fist on
the sky so explain the the famous
Russian attorney who says she was in
there to talk about Russian adoptions
right then others say she's there to
peddle dirt on Hillary Clinton how we
see a client of Glenn Simpsons yeah the
whole idea about her talking about
adoptions that's part of her effort to
rollback the Magnitsky Act which was
sanctioning Russian officials and other
associates of Vladimir Putin so again
Glenn Simpson who was hired by the
Clinton campaign to produce the dossier
allegedly unraveling unearthing Trump's
ties to Russia is actually working on
behalf of pro-kremlin interest
that's what Natalia vassal net Skye is
doing in that meeting she's actually
pushing a campaign that Glenn Simpson is
partnered with to rollback American
legislation on Putin regime officials
and other associates
so a Glenn Simpson client is the key to
the case that the Trump family was
involved in colluding with the Russian
government right Glenn Simpson also the
person paid to assemble a dossier
proving collusion between the Trump
family in the Russian government so why
is this not a widely known fact I mean
look I think that basically what's
happened here is I think that we've seen
fusion GPS and we've seen the press
basically take a picture right and the
picture is of Donald Trump and other
Trump campaign members in a meeting with
a Russian lawyer and then they wrote the
caption underneath and what does the
caption say collusion the other caption
is something the real caption is
something else the facts are different
the fact that vessel Nets Kyah is
they're working on a case that Glenn
Simpson is also working on they're
partnered on the same job on behalf of
pro-kremlin interest so yes it's an
enormous issue that that has been
misreported or underreported since the
story first broke a little more than a
year ago now in 2017 reporting the 2016
meeting it's just an amazing fact it's
just it's really a a year ago I never
woulda believed any of this Lee Smith
thank you for that there's great anger
Thanks